hello there perhaps you noticed that
miss coffee bean is fascinated by lots
and lots of data
too fascinated if you ask me
with the scaling law paper in vision
transformers and now with how to train
your vit we are seeing impressive
performance of big transformer models on
lots and lots of data
with the release of how to train your
vit more than 50 000 models yes 50 000
have been released by the google brain
team
which is great because these models do
not have to be trained again and the
whole community can start using them
miss coffee bean did you sound the
foundation models alarm
oh come on who invited the term
foundation models into this video
miss coffee bean we need to talk
about the question whether vit counts as
a foundation model about the term
foundation model itself and about some
interesting points we saw in the
foundation model paper like the question
of understanding
and generalization power of models under
distribution shift miss coffee bean are
you ready for this
should we sound the rant warning alarm
feel free to skip through the video
chapters when it gets too much
while reading the abstract of this new
oh well who are we kidding it's machine
learning so this is already old
i was saying that i was reading the
abstract of how to train your vit which
explains to us how vision transformers
can be adapted to many downstream tasks
oh so this must be one of these
foundation models right
you know this paper rather a book
published by everyone at stanford where
they rename pre-trained models into
foundation models but there's no mention
of vid or dit just a reference among
many others to the paper about emerging
properties in vision transformers that's
it so why didn't they mention vit
honestly no idea let's check the
definition of foundation models to see
for ourselves a foundation model is any
model that is trained on broad data at
scale and can be adapted fine-tuned to a
wide range of downstream tasks vit is
trained on more than 300 million images
but is this broad enough how broad is
broad data at scale is something like
imagenet with 1.2 million images large
scale
i mean it seems like 2009 it was but
nowadays imagenet counts as academic
sized data set and it is put into
contrast with the hundreds of millions
of images vit was trained on so is
imagenet now big or small what scale
does scale have
well
let's suppose that 300 million images
for vit a scale that not many have is
large enough so condition of broad data
at scale for vit check
second condition can be adapted to a
wide range of downstream tasks but again
how should we know from this definition
that this enumeration is wide enough
what about now
how wide is wide well how is this
definition of any help in making
terminology more accurate you see me and
miss coffeebean have a love hate
with the term miss coffee bean the
youtuber loves it
i am the phd student and i am mad at
this as a small bystander to this pr
stunt that seems to have worked quite
well even if there are enough people in
ai who criticize this move there are
people already happily starting to use
this term of foundation models small phd
student rant here but was it really a
necessity that now every time one uses
this term that fits everywhere and just
replaces some older non-attributed terms
all these researchers have to receive a
whole citation okay but forget about
this let's look specifically at the
section where they explain why they
chose the name they did they say that
this term foundation models will fill a
void
what i was not really aware of we cite
existing terms capture the technical
dimension because the grandeur of a
paradigm shift is not visible so their
idea is let's replace exact technical
terms through a vague term which is
literary and metaphoric in its
interpretations because on one side we
have the confused researcher about when
to use or not to use the term foundation
models
for the vit example or resnet but on the
other side the uninformed broad public
and possibly supporters of this new
center for research on foundation models
should suddenly get it that it is about
models laying a foundation but that a
foundation does not build an entire
house
this is deep
well i'm making miss coffee been angrier
and angrier because she does not agree
with me you know miss coffee bean who
was created by a pr move herself
actually loves this and it's nice it's
more drama more pr more catchy terms for
grant applications and paper titles so
do not forget to add this one to your
list even more from the perspective of
someone who is not involved in research
on these models or from the perspective
of someone who likes to educate the
broader public about ai what is really
really great about this paper is that it
is an extensive place to learn all about
these big models for anyone not closely
familiar with them it's like a manual so
she wishes you happy reading of a
document where researchers had no space
limit
now not really to spare you the reading
but more to give you some spoilers here
are miss coffee beans favorite takes
from this book or paper of 200 pages
whatever
it was really scary to read the section
about incentives where they say that we
decide just as the pharmaceutical
industry has little incentive to devote
significant resources to the research
and development of malaria treatments
because poor people cannot afford
medications the tech industry has little
incentive to devote significant
resources to technologies designed for
improving the condition of poor and
marginalized people
so in contrast universities are much
much better but i don't know if things
are so black and white when miss coffee
bean sees the broad spread aversion of
academics for actually doing science
communication and that there are
companies that do better than described
here
we're not that sure then miss kofibin
and me both like the section on
understanding where it is all about the
questions that are going on lately after
seeing how good these models become but
do they understand does gpt 3 understand
we even had a video previously about the
restricted question of whether a text
only system could ever understand asked
by bender and caller and a follow-up on
what more is required to get to
understanding based on a paper by bisque
and collaborators the view in the
foundation models paper is a little
broader with snapshots taken from
different philosophical sites and you
know when it gets philosophical opinions
tends to diverge the paper tells us that
there is the metaphysical question of
what understanding really means and then
people's answers diverge but supposedly
we get an answer there on which we all
agree then we need to go further into
the
epistemological question which is a
fancy word for saying that we are unsure
about whether we would ever be able to
exhaustively test and analyze and
dissect the model to know whether it has
understanding this means that even if a
model would have understanding we would
not be able to say whether it does so
because we might not have the right
means or even the right measure for
detecting understanding
the authors highlights that it's the
same with intelligence with the turing
test that has been passed many times
already but we still don't call these
systems intelligent because we keep
moving the goal post we even like to
leave the question open of whether
understanding even matters in these
models right now we do not know and
people keep disagreeing exactly like me
and this coffee bean my opinion me as a
researcher
is that understanding is a crucial
component for these models only then we
can trust them be comfortable with them
and rely on them when they do difficult
things like driving our cars or caring
for us and then there's miss coffee
being the incarnation of pragmatism she
thinks that we do not need models to
understand for us to comfortably
interact with them we interact with
things that we do not understand daily
when browsing a website most people do
not know about ip addresses and dns
servers or any other technicalities of
the internet but they use and trust it
nonetheless miss coffee bean thinks that
in the future at the moment when these
models will get close to perfect it will
all become a risk assessment supposedly
we know from lots of data statistics
that a self-driving car crashed hundred
times in the last 20 years and otherwise
was driving perfectly throughout the
whole world
but we know that there were thousands
human drivers that crashed due to
alcohol consumption or whatever in the
last 20 years do we really need to know
that a self-driving car understands
to trust it more and to use it
what do you think about this let us know
the comment section is for you to crash
otherwise in the paper it was nice to
see more emphasis put on the data
creation process and the push to create
a data hub for the whole community
because these models rarely and by that
we actually mean never get any better
than the data they are trained on then
it is even more surprising to see how
the point on distribution shift was set
up so this is a point we really thought
we need to discuss it's not about the
message itself with which we think we
agree but about how the message is
presented we cite existing work shows
that pre-training on unlabeled data is
an effective general purpose way to
improve accuracy on ood which is out of
domain test distributions this and
almost every other machine learning talk
with coffee bean heard makes it sound
like
increasing the amount of training data
increases the out of domain performance
don't get us wrong we completely agree
that scaling up the data increases
performance but we do not really agree
on this strong emphasis on ood so ood
means that we have types of data that
the models has not yet seen this is of
course in contrast within distribution
which contains types of data that models
have already seen i mean look at the
example here in distribution is
satellite data of the whole world since
the model was pre-trained on that then
how is satellite data of malawi out of
distribution since malawi is part of the
world
we are all these skeptics in a sense we
have not yet seen these models perform
well out of their comfort zone which is
ood what we have seen is how expanding
the amounts of training data the
in-domain distribution was expanded a
lot too
we just make the training data so huge
that most of the testing you do is
actually still in training distribution
in other words nothing will be ever out
of training distribution if the whole
world was seen during training and
combine this with our incapability of
really imagining huge data amounts and
we are ready to think that we have
created something more powerful than it
actually is
why can gpt 3 write html code and
perfect this infused learning because it
had html codes during the pre-training
stage already but why do we talk about
data samples like they were out of
distribution when they are mostly an
interpolated version of a sparsely
sampled distribution
the authors give the example of clip
performing well on imagenet sketch but
of course it was trained on 400 million
images from the internet where enough of
them were containing sketches to us it
seems like foundation models are not
really a solution to the generalization
problem since one just completely
resolves the need for generalization by
letting the model interpolate or even
specialize during fine tuning but not
generalize
we do not negate the advantages of
scaling up data it works very well to
increase the data so much that
everything becomes in distribution but
we just advocate for more honesty about
where the performance gains of
foundation models actually come from
if you're looking for real alternatives
and real out of domain generalization
where your model can really handle new
data that is substantially different
from what it has seen before look in
other places someone in this community
proposed jeff hawkins html model check
it out otherwise we really enjoyed and
appreciated the section on alignment
where the authors say that one challenge
is the misalignment between the
foundation model's training objective
and the desired behavior this really
speaks from our heart and if you want
our take on this in relation to clip
watch our video where we highlight how
alignment has already started to be a
problem when clip's normal behavior
following its training objective was
blamed to have been the victim of an
adversarial attack
well wow this was the video
congrats for making it until the end but
what do you think about foundation
models let us know your perspective in
the comments to help settle my
divergence with miss coffee bean do not
forget to like and subscribe
[Music]
you